what's up everybody Welcome to a very
special episode of visual effects artist
react we are joined here on the couch by
Paul debevo you've seen hdri's lighting
a scene you know if you may have seen
the light stage when you've seen like
actors getting their faces captured this
man invented that it's just an absolute
honor to have him on the couch Paul
thanks for joining us thanks it is so
cool to be here the reason why this
episode is special is because
iconic films in history so you're gonna
actually get some real life context as
to how this technology evolved into the
movies we love today it's a lot we're
gonna get into it just buckle up
[Music]
so Paul it's an honor to have you on the
couch I feel like should be calling you
like Professor de bevik Dr de bevik Dr
Paul's totally fine it's an honor to me
to have you on this couch because you
have influenced my career so greatly in
my knowledge so greatly because you've
communicated things that are complicated
in such an effective approachable way
well it's super exciting to be here your
videos are super fun they're doing such
great work to get visual effects
knowledge out there to demystify but
also just Inspire as to what you can do
creatively and for a period of my career
I was able to when I was at Berkeley we
do a siggraph research paper in the fall
and then in the spring let's make a
movie using this new technique that we
just came up whether it was you know a
photorametry system or hdri lighting or
the first light stage well okay so I I
think we should probably start by taking
a look at the campanilli film that you
made campanilli campanellia campanilly
I worked with a couple architecture
students to get this miniature of the
Campanelli made okay I found an
undergrad student named Chris Wright who
was amazing with the Steadicam shot and
then we tracked the shot what a nice cut
right there and now we're flying around
the tower so this is from a set of
photos taken from the top of the tower
of the campus and then photos taken of
the tower some on the ground and also
working with a architecture Professor to
do kite aerial photography to get the
views above normally you would just fly
a drone around but when you're filming
this like drones weren't a thing at all
so it's like how do you get these aerial
photos
kites yeah yeah it's the camera on a
kite the real magic though is that you
know for the first time in this film we
were seeing both a building
reconstructed in photography and its
context all around it and that's when we
were getting kind of like a little
tingle down the spine that like we've
recreated reality you can believe it and
part of that is the lighting because the
lighting on that scene that you see
coming from the scene is consistent with
the lighting that you see on the tower
and you just believe that the whole
thing belongs together at that point
yeah it's kind of like the unsung hero
of the shot is the background because
you know look at this now it feels a
little unremarkable because we're so
used to drones in Google Earth but back
then there were no drones and there was
no Google Maps or Google Earth I mean
photogrammetry was not really a thing
it's like this is the the birth of all
of that so the photogrammetry system
that I went on to build at UC Berkeley
was designed to do architectural scenes
and one of the things that we built into
this photogrammetry system was indeed
view dependent reflection when you do
renderings for the Berkeley Tower as you
rotate around of the texture maps are
actually fading to different original
projected views depending on the virtual
Viewpoint to try to make it look like
view dependent Reflections I actually
didn't realize that specific part of
that that makes it so much more advanced
yeah than what I had thought you can
keep an eye on the clock to see what
you're describing okay absolutely yeah
the clock actually changes time as you
see it so one of the biggest reasons it
was helpful to have this this relatively
photoreal version of the campus is for
the match move shots which is what the I
I like this shot right here it goes from
this to like a perfect match move like
the the momentum of the camera it's just
so Flawless so like yeah I mean how'd
you do that well
fortunately the architectural model that
was built had the same proportions as
the real Tower had the same proportions
as the CGI Tower so the way that the
facade photogram trick modeling system
worked is that you would Mark edges in
one image and then Mark similar edges in
another image similar models in another
image and then you tell the computer
what you want to build the scene out of
I want this like a wedge here a block
here a frustum here so once we'd locked
in the size and shape of the
campanillion how that was built we could
Mark edges on the miniature and then
lock all of the dimensions of the Tower
and just solve for a camera position I
love how brute force in raw all this is
but also like it speaks to I think a
philosophy that stands out in your work
I think that's unique to you which is
you didn't have to do a match move
transition shot exactly like this is the
technology on display right here you
didn't have to do the smash moves but
you did and it makes it so much more
magical how do you I mean the question
is like how do you make a film that's
like worth watching independent of the
technology how do you make it
interesting and I just thought that this
idea of having there's really three
versions of the Campanelli here there's
an Architects model there's the real
Tower and there's the CGI Tower and we
do a transition between all of them in
the process of that so the siggraph 97
electronic theater played in The Shrine
Auditorium like all week and one of the
people who saw that is a visual effect
supervisor who at the time was trying to
figure out how to do some shots in a
film where all of a sudden time slows
down and the camera whips around
somebody who's doing something
interesting and what movie is that
Infinity
help
so this is one of the most iconic visual
effect shots of all time yeah pretty
universally agreed that this is a very
iconic moment it's amazing it's always
like the slo-mo aspect of Neo and the
bullets flying by that get all of the
buzz but people take for granted one of
the most important aspects of this which
is the background the background is a 3D
scene but no one realizes that it looks
so real they kind of knew that they had
to build a big camera array and that
they'd be filming the actors in the
studio and they'd have to put in a
virtual version of the background and
that virtual version of the background
needed to intercut with stuff that was a
couple shots before and a couple shots
after that was shot really up there and
it had to match move exactly how they
happened to lay out their camera array
and that's when John saw that there was
a way to take photos of a scene turn it
into a 3D model that looks pretty much
like the scene and now you have complete
camera control and you can match move
that in and you can do the shot that you
need with that background being around
those actors and moving exactly the same
as the camera array and if you look at
the back of this there's even a little
instance of kind of some view dependent
texture mapping so if you look at the
back building there's a reflection on
the building if that was just a texture
as the camera moved that reflection
would be like it's painted on the build
but you can see how the reflection
slides underneath like the window slats
that are holding it there it's like an
actual reflection yeah and is that
example of the view dependent texture
that is the view dependent effect you're
seeing on those Reflections and it keeps
your scene from looking like everything
is painted on and chalky it's not the
painted shoebox effect and in the view
dependent texture mapping you know
chapter of my PhD thesis that was the
idea is that you would be able to bring
more life to your scenes by kind of
representing the lusters and the
reflections that you see amazingly they
completely just reset the clock on time
slice they did the best possible thing
you could possibly do with the
technology with an amazing movie an
amazing story amazing everything and all
of a sudden it's all new again
hey it's me Brandi O'Daniel in this
episode of what's happening in the VFX
industry we've heard that Paul De bevik
has come to the corridor digital studio
right here in Los Angeles and we have
the pleasure of going to talk to some
people about what they think that means
come on with me what would you say if I
told you that today's episode is brought
to you by raycon
probably something like that great Hey
Dean D with Paul debevic downstairs what
would you say if I told you that raycons
have eight hours of play time with
seamless Bluetooth pairing oh I I don't
see what that has to do with Paul De
bevik but that sounds really great
that's a lot of play time and they come
in a convenient carrying case that you
can easily fit in your pocket and they
recharge your earbuds at the same time
personally when I'm not reporting on the
VFX industry I like to go for a nice
easy jog I put in my raycons they fit
comfortably you know the music helps me
Zen out and focus on the really
important things hey Sam what would you
say if I told you that raycons are half
the price of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market I would say that's
impossible
it's not it's actually happening right
now on byracon.com if you want to get a
pair of raycons for yourself and get
that awesome premium audio experience
for half the price of other premium
wireless earbuds head on over to buy
raycon.com Corridor crew and you'll get
15 off your purchase hey Wren hi hey as
a professional VFX wait aren't you
downstairs right now
isn't how did you get up here
so if your contribution to
photogrammetry and projection mapping
and image based modeling led to the
Matrix but we're about to jump into hdrs
and image-based lighting hdrs are the
secret to making your CGI look real when
you're trying to composite it into real
world footage so one of the really cool
things you do is you just go to your
spot wherever you're filming get a 360
image of that area as an HDR and you can
use it as lighting on your 3D model to
make it look like it was lit with what
was in that scene it's used in big
movies it's used in Scrappy Indie VFX
YouTube channels it's used in video
games it's used all over the place it is
one of the defining things in modern CGI
it turns out the world has an amazing
dynamic range of like from how dark
things are to how bright things are and
our eyes have all these adaptation
methods so that you know we're in a
dimly lit room inside we can see stuff
and if we go outside then you know our
irises get smaller the dopes and pumps
into the retina and then we can see
outside the bright stuff but we still
can't look directly at the sun which is
still like tens of thousands sometimes
brighter than anything else I mean at
least I say you can't you should not you
should not put on the special glasses
please cameras aren't designed for that
cameras are designed to take a picture
of you and originally to print it out on
photo paper where everything on the
photo paper is going to be between like
how reflective something can be when
it's white and how reflective it can be
when it's black but if you then want to
actually say I'm recording values of
light in the real world and I want to
include how bright that light is and how
bright that is and gosh even how bright
the sun is it turns out computers are
fine with this it's just software image
rendering software wasn't designed so
what you're talking about is literally
the birth of image based lighting which
is a very very common thing that any
visual effects artist has dealt with
today
[Music]
proper Overexposed bokeh this is one of
those things where I saw it it was
immediately like oh my gosh this is the
first time I'm seeing those bright
highlights that I see in real life and
I'm seeing light act like it does in
real life I'm seeing exposure changes
when light is reflected or going through
like something that's dim or that
filters out the colors it's like I had
never seen this before because up to
this point at any point if you wanted to
light something in CGI you had to place
the points by hand or the lights by hand
and dial in the values by hand eyeball
it hope your artistic interpretations
close enough you're like a classic
painter trying to paint the real world
and picking like your paints to match
the real world values yeah and so this
process of like hey let's just measure
the light that was there used physically
based rendering to illuminate the CGI
object with the light that was there
then it should look like it was there
and we can have fun and make a film
where something happened that you know
maybe not actually occurred and this was
game changing for me and for for lots of
I mean for the entire industry this is
game changer there's also literally
changed games
you got a whole refraction Shader going
on with the big glass ball too well I
mean thank you Ray tracing and thank you
Radiance for all the refractions and
stuff but the hdri map I shot it in the
late afternoon in the UC Berkeley
Eucalyptus Grove I shot it on a mirror
sphere so I modeled this scene I like
wrote little equations to make the
little twirly things there in some
procedural language and I got you know I
wanted diffuse I wanted metal I wanted
refraction I got like all the materials
that you can do and you just basically
asked Radiance to render it and it
lights that scene with that light and it
looks very real but on top of that I
wrote a couple of filters that would
produce these Bloom effects and then on
top of that I also did a vignetting
filter so when you get out to the
corners of the image it's actually
multiplying down by two stops by the
time you're in the corner of the image
so when you rotate around look at that
bright region go into the corner and it
exposes it down and you see more detail
when that bright spot floats into the
corner and you probably weren't
conscious of that the first time you saw
the film but it just feels right because
that's how light and Optics work in the
real world so I mean it was nice looking
at the Spheres in the forest I got a lot
of good feedback on the film I told it
kind of blew up the discussion board
that industrial Light Magic after graph
98 and they actually invited me to come
speak about it so I have like a photo of
my first slide in Sea theater with R2D2
over there before I gave my talk but you
know it just felt like hey we could
probably do more
now this is like such a flex in 1999.
this is like you're just out there in
this like CG bodybuilding competition
and showing off the biggest biceps
anybody's ever seen very happy with that
shot I mean we've got monoliths
obviously there's some 2001 in this here
that shot with the emotional is the most
flexiest of all these shots
simulations but also seeing the proper
like yeah High dynamic range streaks of
light yeah in the motion blur it ended
up I don't think I knew when I started
the film that like the coolest part
about it would be just seeing the
reflections whipping across these black
monolith surfaces and that was like that
was a total win because Radiance didn't
have motion blur built into it so I had
to render every frame I think for this
shot I think everything got rendered
over a hundred times with just tiny
little steps oh and then you had to like
go through in bracket you took you took
all those brackets and merged them
together they're all at the same
exposure but they're all high dynamic
range all of them have little points of
light that go way above the white point
and then we're using that high dynamic
range motion blur to average them
together still in floating Point space
so you don't clip the renders the
renders have the full range and then
when you average them together you can
still get that bright streak and then
there's also what we had to do for the
floor because we notice the floor gets
both shadows and Reflections right and
normally if you have like these image
based models then they're just going to
be you know reflecting the same pixel
values that you saw in the original
photo us but we're putting monoliths on
top of the floor so this monoliths need
to cast Shadows on the floor and so you
know we modeled the floor as a flat
polygon but what we had to do is we had
to take it from being an emissive
texture to being the correct reflective
texture like a normal texture map such
that if it receives the light that we've
reconstructed it then looks the way that
it did in the photos so basically to
inverse out the life we had to inverse
light we had to inverse light the floor
of Saint Peter's so that we could cast
Shadows on it and we could get the
reflections on it it's all just math
like light and math it's all linear it
all works if you do the math right you
can actually get the light to look right
it's very nice that it's all linear it's
too bad we screwed it all up in our
whole image Pipeline with everything not
being linear anymore slow progress if
this isn't nerdy enough for you we have
a less edited version of this where our
technical discussions really shine
through the roof on this if any guys
hopped over and saw the Tim Miller
episode you know what we're talking
about it's a good episode it's a special
one so yeah Corridor digital.com
is somebody there so this is X-Men which
came out in 2000 and tell us a little
bit about the connection between this
and the work that you were doing so I
think this is the first shot in a
feature film that used hdri lighting
techniques directly inspired by the
research I was doing and in this scene
Senator Kelly who's Afflicted with some
mutant thing he melts right in front of
uh Halle Berry's character here
this is it
yeah and now oh now he's transparent
and
Compton to the real water there and just
looked at the lighting on the CGI water
looks so close to the lighting on the
real water at the end of the shot well
even this like the dude has like proper
subset for scattering on his digital
skin and and this ends up being a really
difficult CGI lighting integration
because it needs to do diffuse surfaces
and specular surfaces and both real
stuff that's actually on the table lit
by that light and CGI versions that also
need to look like they're lit by that
same light so everything just kind of
has to work let's quickly Define
specular and subsurface just for the
audience absolutely so when light hits
skin some of it bounces right off the
surface and that's the specular
highlights like right now I should have
like a little specular highlight on my
nose and my my forehead from these light
sources like the shiny Parts yeah the
shiny part is the color of the color of
the light source and then some of the
light actually refracts into the skin
bounces around in the bed most likely
gets absorbed and never comes out but
the stuff that does come out has picked
up the color of the skin become diffused
it's moved around a little bit and it
diffuses back out as subsurface
scattering you're showing subsurface
scattering all the way through your
finger from that bright LED light in the
back of your phone from the other side
and lo and behold it's not the white
color of your LED it's the red color of
all that blood that's in your skin
and what they did is they brought a
mirror ball on set and they got
different exposures of the ball and they
used that to do a reconstruction of the
lighting of the scene that was based on
the high dynamic range imagery and then
simulating it with the hdri lighting for
that and the shot ended up looking
pretty good once we'd made the camping
the only movie once we made Fiat locks
it seemed like we need to turn our
attention to the human face that at some
point I need to be able to make a movie
that actually has some people in it or
else we're not really making movies
right yeah and I realized you know what
if I got an image of a face lit from
every direction light can come from one
at a time I can compute from that data
what it should look like with an image
based lighting environment and that was
the Genesis of the first light stage it
had a single 250 watt Spotlight so if
you swing this light around you get
people lit from any lighting direction
and then the goal is we're going to take
this person we're going to light them
with a lighting environment they've
never been to and we're going to do it
with what we call a reflectance field
it's a data set of every direction light
can come from sometimes today these are
called olats because it's one light at a
time now that we build light stages that
have lights in all different directions
we can just have the actors sit there in
less than a second get every single
lighting direction and it's a readout of
how your face reflects light and it has
all the specular response the diffuse
the subsurface the self-shadowing the
inner Reflections so you've now been
able to figure out how to like properly
re-light an actor and whatnot but
they're in like this little stage how is
this accessible for a movie production
well the next thing that we did is we
actually used our video projectors to do
a 3D scan of the face while they were
there we started projecting these real
relightable textures onto the facial
geometry and we had to do some special
work to make those relatable textures
view dependent we had to kind of strip
the specular off and then re-synthesize
it from New normals and that became like
the rest of our stereograph 2000 paper
there's a really ingenious solution you
had here to get the surface details
where you used polarized light and you
took one picture of the face where you
basically polarized out the reflections
you took another picture where you had
the reflections and you just did a
difference between the two yep and that
gave you just the specular then only the
spec will reflect the specular and
that's what you're seeing right there
this only reflection of the skin it
turns the next chapter of the story for
that is that we got a call from Scott
stockdike at Sony Pictures image works
and they were doing the visual effects
for Spider-Man 2 right
oh
they want to do a very photoreal Doc Ock
that could climb up buildings and be in
stunt scenes and look like Alfred Molina
and like a real human Alfred Molina we
built a second light stage out of strobe
lights that only took eight seconds to
scan and we got like a massive
reflectance field data set of Alfred
Molina they brought Toby Maguire in for
like three shots of the film where he's
stopping the train and they built a
production pipeline based on our
surgraph 2000 paper to do the relatable
textures with diffuse and specco and all
that for the digital humans in
Spider-Man 2. and for 2004 that was a
pretty darn good digital face that they
did and they won an Academy Award for
best visual effects hey heck yeah this
was a major milestone in being able to
reproduce Digi doubles we actually at
this point had built a better mousetrap
and that got us Benjamin Button they
brought the entire cast of Avatar over
and our scans were used to kind of morph
into the navi versions of the actors
probably the most
um kind of impactful project I got to be
part of in the movie industry with this
was scanning Paul Walker's brothers for
furious 7. to help what a digital create
a Digi double of Paul Walker who had
passed during the production amazing and
doing about 300 shots of that I just am
so excited to see people playing with
new technology but also doing creative
things with it so getting ideas out
there showing that there's a creative
application that there's a creative
route to do something new and exciting
with it is super important for moving
the field forward yeah I mean you guys
do that well thank you
appreciate that so this show is special
because we have somebody joining us
who's helped invent the technology
behind our favorite visual effects and
movies what are some other Technologies
you guys would love to see explored not
movies for us to look at but the actual
Tech behind them and we will invite in
the creators to see what we can teach
you about them oh by the way we got a
cool video coming out tomorrow we know
how much you guys like the debunking
videos and we've got a very cool spicy
one for you about alien orbs we've got a
very crazy twist at the end of this one
so make sure you subscribed for that
because if you're not you might miss it
and that would make me sad
okay so I feel like we've just barely
scratched the surface because there's so
much more there's a whole era of
shooting and volumes and led screens and
all the technology you've developed
around that but I'm about to save that
for potentially a later day is there
anywhere people can go to look at more
of your research to learn more about
what you've done yeah well I've got a
website that's been up since 1994.
www.debec.org and there's a YouTube
channel with all the electronic theater
pieces that you can get there yeah you
know what for me like getting to film
this episode of react has been special
because it's very much a full circle
thing for me it's the research you've
done the way you've shared it the way
you shared knowledge really helps me get
into the world of visual effects and
helping get into the world of CGI and
now you know a couple decades later
we're actually sitting on the couch with
you getting to talk to you and hear
these stories and it's been just amazing
for me so Vegas it is a huge just
walking in that door and saying oh my
God that's the couch yeah and here we
are thanks so much this has been awesome
yeah I appreciate it serious I I rarely
get to have like these types of nerdy
technical discussions so this was like a
real treat for me so thank you thanks
and thanks for everything you do to show
people what's possible with the visual
effects absolutely likewise
yeah for real